here is Karin Jean-Pierre our White
House Press Secretary saying that minor
sex change surgeries are between a
parent and a child and government should
stay out now it's ironic that they've
suddenly become libertarian on this
we'll get some more on that in a second
and then today Indiana just uh banned
puberty blockers hormone therapies and
gender transition surgeries for minors
I'm wondering what the president's
reaction is to the Indiana Governor
signing that bill into law and does the
president have a position on at what age
these kinds of therapies and surgeries
are appropriate got something for a
child and and their parents to decide
it's not something we believe should be
decided by by legislators so I'll leave
it there it is absolutely incredible the
hypocrisy with these people I know
hypocrisy is dead but their hypocrisy is
incredible the same people who will be
upset if a parent comes to a school
board meeting saying I don't want drag
queens dancing in front of my children
they're the same ones that say it's up
to a parent and a child to decide if
they should have their nuts chopped off
you see the irony of this right like if
a parent objects to a book or objects to
a drag queen then the parent is
completely out of control in their
far-right Maniac if as long as the
parent is for the genitals being chopped
off then it should be between a parent
and a child these people want the
government to be involved in absolutely
everything suddenly when some red states
are saying you know maybe government
does have a little bit of a role to have
something to do with a functioning state
maybe we should be protecting children
it's something like that and now they're
upset about that but suddenly they're
all Libertarians they're all libertarian
it's absolutely incredible by the way
cringe John Pierre cringe that's all
right cringe I wish you were a
Libertarian I wish you would get the
hell out of my life I wish Joe Biden had
nothing to do with my life or any of you
people you're right stay out of our
Lives most things should be done between
a parent and a child how about you give
us our tax money back that you steal for
your crazy Wars and everything else how
about you just stay out of our Lives all
together and we'll make decisions for
ourselves but you guys are pushing this
stuff on us constantly
[Music]
thank you